the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing it in the night
pants Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social media uh look man I want to thank
you guys for your support of the special
Lefty son it's over on my YouTube now if
you haven't watched it yet watch it
share it get it out there that's how
these things grow uh and look if you
gotta have more of this then you gotta
check out the patreon we had a huge uh
new amount of subscribers from two bears
coming over uh especially after that
double lung transplant story so I'm
telling you it is the Honeydew with
y'all and y'all got the wildest stories
I've ever heard in my life alright if
you're looking for a new podcast check
out an old podcast called The Crab Feast
it's Audio Only and uh there's a wild
group out there still doing things all
right I'm out on tour right now June
23rd and 24th you can catch me in Tacoma
Washington July 7th and 8th Appleton
Wisconsin we're adding a bunch more
dates we'll have dates all the way
through this year and then the next here
as well coming up here very soon but
that's the biz you guys know what we're
doing over here we highlight the low
lights I always say that these are the
stories behind the storytellers I'm very
excited to have this guest on today for
the first time here ever on the Honeydew
ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Ollie siddique welcome to the Honeydew
oh thank you for having me thank the
Honeydew which is a good melon you like
it yeah especially when you get a good
one you know that's it yeah when you get
a good one it's always sweet you know
just like when you when you get a good
cantaloupe you know you get a bad
cantaloupe you hate cantaloupe from that
point on but you know honeydew is a good
melon but it's not good often you know
what I mean it's like it's like four
weeks out of the year you know what I
mean you gotta get them and that's the
thing that's why this whole show is
named that everybody
just eats around the honey doing that
fruit cup and they leave the Honeydew
and I'm leaving this Diner one night
after I did the same thing and I'm
looking at the tables and they are
littered with honey doing I was like man
that's
a perfectly good fruit that most people
just throw to the side and then I was
like man that's me in life
I'm a perfectly good person that people
keep throwing away and I was like I'm
gonna lean into that [__] and we'll
highlight the bad times and like because
everybody's Instagram is their ESPN's
their Sports Center top 10 their
highlight all of its [__] I'm paying
people to do it now I I took that Chris
thank you Krista Stefano I took that
[__] Chris Stefano approach and I'm
like I'm getting the [__] off of this
[__] man it's weird that that's what
people do just all they good stuff you
know I I show a lot of bad stuff you
know because I I box so every every
response session don't go my way it
doesn't at all
like some some of them just went totally
left I thought I had it no not today I
haven't no I did not have it you know
sometimes I bite off more than I can
chew because I'm in a gym with Pros so
every once in a while a pro look at me
and say something I'm like what you
looking at
oh Ali what's up well get your stuff
then and I'm in the ring um last one was
Todd manual
um yeah I just watched our manual fight
Victor Ortiz
[Applause]
[Laughter]
don't look like he got it today
shoot Todd had all of it
he had everything I wanted like
yeah well listen before we get into
anything else please plug and promote
everything you're special your social
media whatever it is you want all of it
oh man
um you can go on my social media is
alicedeek.com or Ali Sadiq on Facebook
all this dick on Instagram Alex Deacon
everything is pushing YouTube always
think I have what a couple specials up
um domino effect domino effect 2 is
coming out June the 4th I ask you about
that yes because I like the idea of
doing that just forget figuring out
another name and just putting the two on
the end of it you know what I mean I
like that is it a continuation of the
first album is it like this Artful thing
where like here's a real part two or
you're just like this is part two it's a
real okay sequel all right so the first
one was 10 to 15. this is 16 to 19. okay
all right It's called Domino Effect 2
lost like got a little under a little
Untitled like John Wick yeah you know so
it's it's a true sequel okay and and I I
had a good time doing it it's the is it
the one it's special out right now yeah
so
um honey I'm about to say honey
um domino effect two is out now so um
where where can they find it YouTube man
I'm I'm staying pretty independent and I
the first one came out on YouTube We
continued our thing on YouTube for the
fans so domino effect three may not be
on YouTube but we yeah we definitely
getting ready to shoot it so you can go
back and watch I think people gonna have
to go watch one yeah if you're a new if
you're a new fan or something like that
you're gonna have to go watch one to
catch up into because it's an actual
true sequel you know it's like you can't
watch Rocky 3 and don't know what
happened in the original one right yeah
so yeah we I think we did a pretty good
job with it congrats and and go watch
that go watch it share it that's how
these things get around and uh are
successful go tell everybody yeah so one
is at like eight point
three million views so we hoping that to
you know gets past that you know those
files past that you know it's a
it was a label of love and it's
definitely different than any special
I've ever seen and definitely anyone
that I've ever done so when people get
people make their own decision on it I'm
not once I release it I'm
I'm hands off I don't care what what
people say or don't say about it yeah
you know I I did it it's done now
there's nothing I can do well he should
have did this and hey it's done now yeah
and there's nobody that Shoulda Woulda
Coulda better than we can about
ourselves nobody because I I actually
have I have seven albums out that they
can go listen to on Spotify XM radio all
that stuff but I've recorded
Maybe
14 15 albums and something was wrong
with one uh it just didn't sound right
to me and and I scrapped it like like I
still have it but it's it's
in the Lost archives yeah so you know
it's I'm a real
hard critic on myself
even when I'm watching a special I only
watch it in the editing and definitely
to finish it because after that I'm just
judgmental of everything every man why
material yeah why do I why not did
somebody didn't tell me that shirt
didn't look right on me you know what
any anything anything so I oh I'ma just
keep not just the material yeah it's not
just the material
yeah you just you just up there yeah
I didn't realize how many times I said
okay I didn't realize how many times I
hit one of those until I started
watching myself back and I'm like I must
have said to nobody's saying anything
about that seven I'm gonna said that 70
times in 10 minutes so y'all just gonna
let me keep saying um yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um
um I'm just full of arms yeah this is
bull like I've I've watched myself with
such a critical eye that
my agents like um this is not going to
end up coming out if you keep yeah
looking at it yeah I said yeah pretty
much because domino effect the first one
I was
um
after my both tapes I was like looking
at like nah a plate failed it it it's
all oh something fell on mine too in the
middle of the whole thing and I'm like
now now the continuity's off you know
what I mean
so one so two so one I totally see it on
the piano but here's the other thing
that that that unfortunately happened
but it was a little silver lining I
spent the month of January in the
hospital my lungs clotted they told me I
should die I'm in there I make it out
and during that my specials with my
buddy Sam who's editing it and he has
already edited some specials before
where he talked about working with
Comedy Central and it's 12 execs giving
notes and he he was like I hate it
because a lot of these people will just
give a note that makes like if if you
say something I'm gonna say I agree with
Ali and uh and let's do this and I just
said something that that doesn't make it
better it just makes a little different
so I can justify my [__] job over
here right so after I'm in the hospital
I'm laying there flat on my back and I'm
talking to him about notes and [__] I'm
clotted up and [__] tubes up my nose and
he goes look I just want to tell you
like go listen I'm gonna tell you
something
you're getting me at the right time if
you think I'm gonna sit here and frame
[__] this special right now dude I'm
giving you an easiest nose pass you ever
got in your life because it doesn't
[__] matter it really doesn't in the
end like we're older I'm 50. I don't
know how old you are now 49. so we go
back to a time when people respected
Framing and lighting and all these days
shits
they don't care it's got 20 million
views you know we care so
um in the end though it really doesn't
[__] matter but it matters to us you
know I'm like God
why why'd that picture have to fall
Comedy Central
I did a half hour special for Comedy
Central
and I I wasn't involved in the editing
process
came out pretty good I did the full hour
special for Comedy Central and I was
involved in the editing process
and
having to
keep going back on emails and they
wasn't understanding so I had to fly to
New York to get them to understand one
thing that I was trying to make clear
you can't move this down that far
because now it makes everything else
doesn't make sense
so they like I wrote it and performed it
a certain way for a reason yeah and it's
not to be chopped up and butchered to
make fit in your 21 and a half no sorry
it was an hour so that would have been
like 44 and a half minutes 44 and a half
yeah so
I I it was it was eight seconds that I
told him that they had to put back and
so now we are watching it and everybody
turns around tonight
oh it's so much better I told y'all that
in the notes
like because I know what it said I know
what it's supposed to say and if you
take that eight seconds out the rest of
this doesn't make sense like at all yeah
because I'm telling the story in
chronological order I'm not I'm not
skipping around you can't move my stuff
like that so when you independent
you can you have a lot more control of
how it goes and then it can you can
regular thing I'm done listening to
notes from other people about my [__]
okay whenever I haven't listened to
it's been successful I didn't listen to
OneNote any [__] executive had
to say about this successful my patreon
which is only five dollars a month
subscribe now successful you know what I
mean the minute you start listening to
all these other people and they're not
even making it better I'm saying it's
just going in circles like we I told you
all this from the beginning 14 emails a
trip across the [__] halfway across
the country to New York hotels all this
[__] just for you guys to go oh yeah
you were right no [__]
because it's my material you know when
it's your life and you talking about
your life
abdominal effect you know every story
I've ever told in in on whatever
platform has been a true story from my
life one of the one of the best stories
that most people know is Mexican got on
boots well that's obviously I was
telling you that's where I learned about
you yeah but then I was fortunate enough
to sit with you for your epic special
and I interviewed you're one of the
comics I got the interview so I got to
know you better I remember telling you I
really want you on this
podcast but you live down in Texas right
yeah right yeah so
um when it when that happened epics was
a great hour my and I did it you did it
to Mint right yeah I was at the man and
I was getting ready to record my my
special
and it was like
is he gonna do two different hours and
Eric Abrams like yeah like he always
does it it was hard because even when I
did The Comedy Central special
I'd got it the first time
so then the second time Eric told me to
go out and have some fun so I just did a
bunch of new different material for the
second table he was like oh so you just
didn't want to do no part of the house
no you said I did
I do some other
s but you know with the networks man
um
I don't know if they know
I just I tell you I'll tell you why they
don't know here's another thing I'm
gonna say we're still here
comedy Central's gone
ain't that something I'm saying this is
supposed to be the central place for
comedy they're they're all but gone this
here we still are I haven't listened to
a [__] note from any of them all
right here I still am here I am I don't
know how long it'll last but I'm still
here I'm still throwing up for cuts and
elbows right the whole way down and and
doing it on your own tutor something
there's
not only do you have the creative
control but there is a more of a
satisfaction so another friend of mine
I'll just make it that
um again editing a special for Comedy
Central and it's 12 execs weighing in
with [__] notes and he's like I
don't I'm telling you they're not
watching it they're not watching it I
know they're not
so he sends another cut in he doesn't
tell the comedian I'll tell you off Mike
who it was because you'll know it
doesn't tell the comedian he does this
sends it off and what he does is just
takes a a random frame oh a kitty cat or
some [__] off of YouTube and just throws
it in the middle like an Easter egg a
frozen frame so that anyone watching it
would say hey that that weird YouTube
thing in there can you make sure that's
out of there guess how many Executives
noted that
probably none none none and it was only
about 20 minutes in it wasn't 45 minutes
in
so it's all you know I'm saying like
they don't care about
and they can't they don't care about
what we care about the way we care about
it they don't they don't and and I think
Netflix is the same
um I think they the same Netflix told me
that
my special was too long
he's a good job me too people are not
people are not paying attention this
long
well on YouTube if they watch it you got
to watch it in order to get the view
they like people
you need eight million people watched it
they wasn't skipping through they didn't
say oh at seven minutes I'm done with it
they like could the comments people know
about the stories in the middle they
like you saying with the cat they know
about the in store they know about all
the the parts of it so
I'm always confused about what they say
is it's not a law I don't even listen
like I don't even listen anymore like
the new special is the i-130
it is what it is it took me that long to
do the show that's how long the show is
and
I have other aspirations for the show
after people watch it I have another
thing that I think I want to do with it
but
when you're telling your life story you
telling stories about yourself
who is it for some somebody else to say
what is relevant in it well that's too
long oh it's still alive I'm still alive
it ain't done yet you know what I mean
it's too long so that's why there's no
more I'm dead yeah it's like it's it's
weird you know and so can we talk a
little bit about your life story then
let's go back to the beginning where are
you from Houston yeah originally you are
I'm a Houston guy okay yeah I've lived a
lot of places I just you know settled my
hat in Houston my mom you know my pops
they moved around but Houston is a place
where we settled in neither one of them
are from Houston but that's what they do
for a living my mom is right now she's a
history professor she used to work for
this computer company called Ferrante
you know she was used to build mainframe
computers whoa yeah your mom used to
build computers back in the old ass
computers yeah the whole computers wow
you know the fiber optic what got her
into that my mom's a real technical
person like really taking [__] apart
when she was a kid all the time like I
don't know that part of it you know what
I mean like this toaster oven ain't
gonna work again yeah it's probably so
good but she's real technical like and
she's she has that I'm technical as well
but not like her she has that laser
focus where she can put little small
things together you know and my older
sisters just like that as well
but she used to be a nurse my mind used
to be a lot of thing I don't even know
how my mom how my mom and my dad met
they was in Job Corps I was like what
the hell were y'all doing that job what
is Job Corps what exactly
it's like what you you you young and you
go work it's like you military smash
just volunteers she's helping people and
stuff they wouldn't even overseas they
was in in town
my dad like like what would y'all do the
job corps like what the old nonsense if
they was young they was young people
what did your dad do my dad used to own
a carrier service and then he sold
cocaine
let me ask you this then was he was he
clean and and working above the belt so
to speak and then figure like white
collar yeah and then saw the opportunity
for the money and was like [__] it I
think we can do this I think that it was
like my pops was selling cocaine it was
like powder and you came in these little
vials you know that's where they dumped
mountains in snow I think because he was
working for a lot of attorneys and uh
this is probably where he got the idea
they were doing it other guys that have
the money yeah yeah they was doing it
back then cocaine was a a very upper
echelon type of drug you know it wasn't
no crack it was yeah it was powdered
cocaine like give me a couple grams and
they snorting so that's why I'm in a lot
of my their friends had these long pinky
nails they get in the jar real quick it
was it was a trip man you would see that
how old are you when you're starting to
put this together 10 11. okay were you
told or when my pops my pops sold it and
so I would come down at night and in the
house I remember
my pot because in in one
people remember that my pops put cocaine
on my tooth when I was 10. with my
wisdom teeth with because he because
they my guns are small and he was like
come here and he used to keep it in this
cool whip Bowl in the refrigerator
container in the fridge or anyone can
get it you know
just in the fridge
just scooping that [__] out if I would
have ever wanted like a uh like what was
what is what was that what's that cake
um Strawberry Shortcake yeah if I would
have wanted to make a strawberry
shortcake the kids would have been told
yeah I would have put the pad over like
a pound of sugar yeah it was weird it
was strawberry cupcake it was in the
refrigerator it's in a in a Cool Whip is
it better to keep it cold I really don't
know about the temperature of cocaine
that's one thing I've never thought
about I always thought it was room temp
I think he was just one of his moves
like if the cops bust in you know they
wouldn't go in the crane open up the
Cool Whip container yeah
but all the all the little brown like it
was a bag of these little brown vials
and they were different sizes but all of
them had black caps and he we I was
seeing this little spoon him and his
friend Ivory and James they would be
putting it in there and it it was never
in a bad
like when I used to see
later on I used to see people with bags
yeah there's a little nickel and dime
bags he had pills in those bags I used
to sell pills too and those I never
forget those bags they had a red you
when they closed at the top it was red
and I I used to think the bag was cool
but cocaine never came in and it came in
the vial now did he know you were
watching this is this all you quietly at
night just me seeing and putting it
together yeah my pox was
was real he tried to be discreet but you
I'm in the house like all the time but
then I end up he had to go somewhere and
then he told me how to sell it with the
like the pills he's like yo people gonna
be coming to this door wait you told me
okay tell him to tell this story right
here this is crazy I remember you told
me about that hey man your kid is
getting ready to go to San Antonio he
came and woke me up how old are you I'm
like 10. like he's leaving yeah he's
leaving he's I'm like where am I
supposed to go you think man go to
school like you've been going to school
10 years old by yourself in a house yep
mom's not there I just live with him
because I was I was living with my mom
at first my mom my sister so then when
he asked who wanted to live with him
like me and
worst decision I've made
1983 had no idea that this is a crazy
man I was doing like I I volunteered to
live with a crazy man but yeah
and you're on in the not just in the
morning in the middle in the middle of
the night he even go to San Antonio hi
what and but
if I think about it he wouldn't be up in
the morning when I got ready to go to
school anyway he would leave my my lunch
money on the on the desk
I would you know go to school I walk
down the street to school I would come
back he wouldn't be there so in his mind
like I'm not here no way man I'm going
out of town just keep doing what you do
the problem is that you know that I'm
going out of town just keep doing what
you're doing right and like but he was a
great man my dad was the craziest man
that I ever known in my life
tell me even when before he died I um I
settled all his debt like he has some
stuff like I hate man like payday loans
like that's old school [__] is still
around yeah man payday loans it's like
they gonna forever be around because
this is not designed for you to pay it
off good point it's like in their mind
like that as soon as you you borrow a
hundred dollars from a Payday person to
Payday Loan people if you don't get that
money back in the next 15 minutes you're
the people 3 700.
man with taxes and fees and handling and
you know
so my dad owed all this money to like
three different payday loan people
and I just paid it off because I didn't
want him to be in debt and then a year
later my my pops died I'm like I should
have waited
one more year they gonna get you happy
and then die that's crazy but
he died right before my special came out
he did yeah so he he used to go to the
library and watch all my stuff on on a
computer like a YouTube there yeah he
would go in and be quoting all my stuff
when I call him you know he's a good
dude you know he wasn't tell me about
the song the drugs out the back door
though he's leaving to go to San Antonio
and he's telling you what not just go to
school not just go to school because
there's a business to be right yeah he
told me Hey listen
people gonna be coming up to this door
when they knock on the door keep
checking on the door go upstairs get the
pills it's fifteen dollars you're saying
get the money first and then give them
the pills but don't open the door always
keep your chain on the door
so
oh man I'm thinking maybe one or two
people
I come by my room was upstairs I just
happened to just keep I just had to come
downstairs and sleep on the couch
because it was so many people
it was like all night these people come
it's like as soon as 12 o'clock as soon
as he left it's almost 12 o'clock here
like 12 15. it was on from 12 15 till I
got ready to go to school and I'm
getting up doing that and I'm I'm in
class
so when I get home he's at the house
and he's sitting there on the couch he
said man come here why am I getting
phone calls from the school talking
about you sleep in the class
I was like yo man I've been up all night
I'm selling these pills have you looked
in the little box upstairs you go to my
it was popping like that
he was like fine
it's been two times that my Daddy has
said the craziest when I got busted for
selling cocaine right
he knew that I was so he gonna come in
he gonna come to the prison wow that
1301 Franklin I'm still in the county
jail he gonna come there don't recognize
him he gonna talk about
man what the hell ain't got into you
say man what are you talking about this
is I'm you I
ain't you and man because he had my
little brother with him and he was I
didn't he was trying to hold face with
my little brother and this dude is crazy
man he's the craziest person did he ever
get busted
my dad never went to jail until
I was already in prison for like maybe
three years
were you guys in prison together yeah no
way it was my pops
my two uncles
um his two brothers
and me we were all in prison my daddy
got locked up for an assault he got into
in a street fight and that how old how
old was he's getting in street fights on
my dad was maybe so if I was
I knew 23-24 so my dad had to be like 40
something like 40
maybe about 45 yeah he gets locked up
and gets put in the same prison you're
in no I'm not in the same person he's in
the same system okay that's what I meant
I mean were you literally there where
you could see each other no he was
always at the same time all in TDC at
the same time but I never forget it
because I remember getting
um 500 dollars
either the 500 or what I think it was
500. 500 put on my books out of nowhere
because he he when he got arrested he
had money on him so the money that he
had on him they put you on they put on
your books
so he transferred five hundred dollars
to me his brother and his other brother
and then wrote a letter to him yeah I
just sent y'all some money the big boss
down here now I'm like
person I know
I know
the craziest person I know
did you send me a letter to my the big
boss the big boss again and it was
terrible my grandmother
I wouldn't let my grandmother come and
visit me this is his mom yes his mom I
wouldn't let my grandmother come visit
me it just seemed like she had been
doing that for so long my uncles had
been
in prison in and out of prison for a
while my dad had never even been in
trouble ever
like my dad was a businessman he had
never been in trouble ever so that's a
that was new for him is like how'd you
[__] up if I did this for all these
years what do you how'd you get arrested
um I talk about it in the in the special
special yes in the special all right a
lot of carelessness on other people's
part not listening to me I feel like
there was something you said to me and
this is because I don't want to dwell on
Prison but
you said to me um
you have to I feel like this is when I
met you people don't realize that you
have to learn how to sell drugs like
you're not good at it at first yeah I
think you told the story about this yeah
yes and domino effect yeah the first one
yeah I wasn't I wasn't a good drug it
don't it's a good point you're not good
at most things we're not good at when we
start and then you learn to be good so
it would make sense mathematically that
as I'm starting out being a drug dealer
I'm gonna mess up a lot I'm gonna Rob
I'm gonna make mistakes until I learned
I'm gonna get robbed I'm gonna it's all
sorts of things that's gonna happen to
you
I think that people get into this get
into their life and because it's so much
fictitious nonsense about that type of
life that oh I I started and I was
already in in the months I was doing
this like books like it it it doesn't go
like that you don't even start with the
amount that you say that you started
with everybody start with a 50 pack and
then and then you go from there you guys
what what is the first thing you start
with Coke yeah before weed or before
pills I'd like if you sell cocaine you
probably never sold weed is that right
yeah I never I never sold marijuana no
like ever
it was
cocaine it was it was no other drug that
was that was prevalent during that time
it's the 80s how old are your kids right
now
oh I have a lot of kids yeah they just
range what to what 29 to two Okay so you
gotta you got a baby I got a big family
as a person who literally worked with
cocaine back then and what it is now
with fentanyl and everything are you
already having talks with them about you
can't even do this stuff anymore it's it
didn't it I know we sound like old man
being like it ain't like it used to be
but it really isn't like it used to be
now yeah it's really not this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp look there's
this stigma about mental health that you
know especially for guys that it's not
okay it's not cool to go to therapy all
that stuff and then you end up spending
all this time if you really look at it
helping other people and how much of it
do you really spend on yourself it's so
easy to get caught up in what everyone
else needs from you and never take a
moment to think about what you need for
yourself but when we spend all of our
time giving it can leave us feeling
stretched thin and burned out therapy
can give you the tools to find more
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind I find myself doing it
all the time I'm helping my daughter my
friends we're doing this we're doing
that we're going here we're going there
and it's like damn I don't take any time
for myself I really need to you know
make myself a priority so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule you just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists anytime for no
additional charge find more balance with
better help visit betterhelp.com
honeydew today and get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash honeydew man I'm
looking forward to this summer I'm gonna
go on a little bit of vacation probably
take my daughter to beach hang out with
family have some friends over cook look
out I want to make sure I'm staying cool
looking good so you know I'm going to be
wearing my doer pants doer makes the
world's most comfortable pants they're
breathable lightweight durable and never
go out of style I got a pair they sent
me a pair of jeans and I want to be
honest with you they're most flexible
relaxing jeans I wear them on stage I
like it I can move in them they're not
tight don't squeeze me up and I can be I
can do physical therapy in them if I
want to do or stretch performance Denim
and lifestyle apparel is made for the
doers they're versatile and made for
anything and everything we do in a day
the technical fabric will keep you cool
when it's hot and warm when it's cool
plus doer is sustainably made from
materials like wood chips plants and
recycled plastic bottles this is a
purchase you can feel good about trust
me you need to add doer to your summer
wardrobe check out doers Flagship stores
in La and Denver or shop online at
shopdoer.com my listeners get 15 off
site wide using my special promo code
honeydew for 15 off your order go now to
shop d u e r.com and use my special
promo code honeydew
shopdoer.com promo code honeydew now
let's get back to the do like
I I haven't had a drug Taco my with my
pre-teens but my older kids 29 24 we've
had a lot of discussions about hey this
is not
it's not even close and I don't think
they would be going towards cocaine or
heroin anyway you know they probably
smoke bud or something but
even with that you know beware where
you're getting anything from you know
because people spraying fentanyl on bud
and that's crazy like
I know somebody who just got busted was
getting ready to go to the feds for
Fentanyl and heroin
and I and I looked at them different
like I didn't know what they were
getting ready to go to jail for and then
oh that's what they got caught with
that's what they got caught with so once
we had the discussion
I literally
looked at them different
because I'm like yo man and I and it
never I never it was your dad all over
again
in this position to and it's back to
being my damn life yeah and I literally
heard the thing like it was heroin if
you're not and I was like
yo and I said it just like this like
what the [__] was wrong with you like
you putting Fentanyl and why did it get
it I said this why didn't they give you
a life sentence yeah I I asked somebody
who a person who is definitely anti
going to prison I asked the person why
didn't they give you a life sentence
like I really wanted to know like
what
like what what happened you got
15 months fed and you got five years
probation you know they gave me 15 they
was trying to give me 99 years for
cocaine 99 years
that lady said I'll never forget it I
got anxiety sitting here here I'm in
court right and I hate to go to the
prison thing too but I'm in court
and Woody Harrison is my attorney who
um real I'm talking about Woody hair
real Harris is my attorney Woody Denson
is the judge okay okay
the the prosecutor
says
well I recommend 99 years and I say who
y'all think y'all
right
so I go back again the lady talking
about 60 years and I six and I said hey
does she know that I am 19 years old
like I'm trying to figure out why in the
hell are y'all coming to me with so much
time
but the first time that's when I got
dropped down the state
when he because the feds I got busted by
the feds so the feds when I first went
to the federal judge that man the
prosecutor was talking about he said I
think he said like 36 months uh 300
something whatever the months were I and
it make it sound like you can do it
because it's months
36 months oh it's nothing 180 months
this is nothing [__] once but I'm good
at math if there's no drug dealers it's
not good in math and we know both
systems yeah so so I'm doing the math
I'm like it
what I I ended up having 50 getting 15
years State okay so without going into
talking about prison so much tell me
about that process so you start you get
federally you get charged first yeah
that is when that when the feds bust you
okay so then and then then how does it
go down the state next is like is that
what your lawyers are working together
working it they working and then they
coming up with all this stuff well this
this is this and this is that now you
get dropped but where are you while
they're this and that and are you in
prison are you home I'm in jail you are
because my bond they they took my bond
you know I went
it's a lot man I I was on Juniper
probation at the time
that's the part I never really tell you
I owned you the first probation
so June for probation is like you on
probation for for a certain amount of
years if you complete your probation
then they clear your record got it okay
so I'm on Juniper
and I'm I'm I'm messing up the whole
time because obviously because I'm
selling dope but because I why wouldn't
I be on June 1st because probation I had
to pay 55 a month with I ain't no job
so how am I gonna pay you the 55 of uh
every every visit without no job and
then when I'm gonna work I go to school
I'm a kid I'm in school
so
I did what I know to do you know I'm I'm
hustling
something that's quick I'm paying them
they 55 I paid they stuff up for the
year
for the year yeah there you go in
advance
um so then
man when I get busted for this because
the juice I shouldn't even been on June
3rd I had a terrible lawyer
um and I get busted with the cocaine
charge
terrible for me it's like I'm on June
the Third
they wanted to give me a bond and then
they brought up well he's a Flight Risk
he's he's on probation right now what
made you think he won so then they I
went to bond reduction
out of the the advice of my attorney
because I could have paid the bond in
full
I had 150 000 Bond I could have paid
that in full to a 10 no I'm gonna need
it
I wouldn't got a 15 grand back yeah and
I would have paid the whole Bond and
the man said
if you do that then you're definitely
yeah
I said what it's like if you pay the
whole Bond you're definitely guilty like
you're definitely guilty like like I'm
like like you're like your time by if
you if you pay that 150 times you're
tying my hands do you know that I just
want you to know that so I said well
what do I do he's like well let's go to
bond reduction and get it reduced and
then we can go from there because he's
trying to make it seem like I don't have
any money
like he's just part and I'm willing I'm
willing to
take this this case as because this I
have a delivery a delivery and a
conspiracy
um
multiple charges it's no just
Deliverance it's a delivery with a
conspiracy to uh there was some intent
in there
to
conspire
to deliver and conspire a controlled
substance
there's a lot in there so man what are
y'all like I had like four charts like
it's not one charge so I'm trying to get
a possession
I'm trying is that like the minimum
thing you want like that's the best
possession is like I'm a user and my
attorney is like so I just won't be
clear
you want me to tell him that you was
using five kilos of cocaine
[Laughter]
that's right yeah so
I mean I'm I'm coming I'm coming to my
meets with him
because first of all I had
three attorneys
the first attorney I got my mom got
and he was garbage because he said he
said something that didn't even make
sense to me he's like where would where
was somebody in that neighborhood get
five kilos of cocaine from like
been doing the South 14.
sir like
we do this all the time so you started
dealing that that weight at 14. okay
when's the first time I wasn't the big
fish on campus
it was like it was this guy
it was some couple guys that had
the the weight what's the most you've
ever had in your possession at once yeah
my possession yeah five six kilos what's
that look like would it take up this
table or have this table no it just a
couple of stacks like not this much
because like you just stack them up what
does it feel like to look at that are
you nervous are you excited like what
was uh oh that was mine but I've seen
way more than that you have hey I've
seen way what's the most you think
and eye line if I had to say it maybe
about 50 60 kilos of dope Jesus
that belong to somebody I'm just in the
room and and I'm coming to get one at
the time from them and they like yeah
this is what I'm doing baby
like but the most money I've ever seen
on a table Yeah Yeah cash actual Cash
Money actual cash bread
I'm gonna say about 1.5 get the [__] out
of here on the table on the table on the
table cash
five tens and twenties how the hell are
these guys not getting robbed and rated
all the time oh man the way people store
money back then yeah give me some
creative ways I've seen money in the
wall
like like they literally plastered
layered in the wall I had I had mine in
a deep freezer
um I've heard that one's also good for
fire too yeah it helps at least you got
at least an extra little barrier in case
there's a fire yeah mild at the bottom
of the deep freezer
the back of the wash the washer and
dryer the whole back of the washer and
dryer okay is I've seen this this was
the craziest thing I said a dude had an
apartment he had a a
um it's a flat home but he had both
sides
like the whole the duplex yeah both
sides right so you would go in his
laundry room
and then he would move the wall out and
he could walk to the other side it
seemed like it was condemned nobody
lived there yeah yeah and it was just
money and dope are you serious the
coldest thing ever all sitting right
there the coldest thing ever without
incriminating myself
layered under the waterbed
nah
in the actual uh you know the hot water
yeah I remember how my cousin move he
moved the water bed it's oh it's a lot
of space under there and how is how the
waterbed is designed all that just
layered
with with money
that's a pretty picture though my mind
yeah
I I ended up it's funny you said the
washer and dryer ended up being
I used to just get my jewelry noticed
and I throw that [__] in the trash
because I did this report on Al Capone
in high school and Al Capone had this
quote saying I refuse to be judged by a
jury of my peers too stupid to get out
of jury duty and I saw I was like well
how do you get out of jury duty and uh
somebody told me well
you just say he didn't get it
I go oh okay
so I would get them for years right in
the trash
because I live in an apartment
yeah I didn't get that and then one day
I get this red notice
I took that [__] in this lady at the
counter I'll never forget she looked
when she goes got a red one huh and I
was like oh [__] I got put on a case for
six five weeks a month and a week and it
was a drug case and these guys were the
worst they were the sloppiest and I kept
thinking man I feel like this is all a
Flim Flam I feel like this is all of us
looking over here and they're moving
real [__] over here you know what I mean
like if you're thinking smart as a
businessman I'm gonna give you these two
over here if I can get 20 over here I'm
gonna give you these two great bust guys
we got two kilos of cocaine me while
there's 18 more going over this way
right
so these guys were meeting Jack in the
Box parking lots and minivans like real
sloppy and that's where they hid their
cash was behind the wall like you said
and then in there the guns were in in
and then the cash was all back behind
and we had they had pictures of
everything yeah everything it was
our guns were
in the
in the garage
in the ceiling like we just moved his
board and we had a bunch of guns up
there but as far as money we kept our
money in different places with the
cruise now I had 84 Grand at my
girlfriend's house in a track just in a
trash bag in ones and fives and you had
you ever been robbed
yes and no like not for my own stuff but
in this in the news special I talk about
getting duct taped and thrown in the
trunk no uh yeah that happened to you
yeah it was I know you talk about it in
stand up but what's going through your
mind then is I really how many people
grabbed you in three three did you try
fighting or did you just knew it it was
because I I'm from this era man of Anna
amongst these like the gun the gun thing
didn't didn't come into play until later
in the dope game like I remember is that
right yeah like when I first I'm 14
right I started selling drugs right
I didn't
nobody around me really had no guns like
it was all just
fair trade the first time I ever even
had my hand on a gun
was I was in his apartment with this guy
and he blew crack smoke in my face
in my mind I was so offended I'm like
are you trying to get me addicted
and so we we end up tussling in his
apartment
and he had a 25 automatic with a wooden
handle and it falls out of his
of his waistband and I grab it and I
didn't even know how to hold a gun I
have I don't have my finger on the
trigger I have my finger on the outside
yeah and I'm saying [__] that I only
heard on TV I'm like get back sucker
like I'm just doing something man I
don't know nothing about no guns and
this is my first and so I I took his gun
from
and so the next time I even add an
encounter with a gun was to do to end up
being my business partner Charles Barber
he pulled out and I never because I
didn't know what the gun was until way
later because it was triangular in the
front
I was like but I just knew it was a 45
because he said it and I was like no
it's a big ass gun and he's like yo you
going you don't because he asked me hey
man what you think about selling for me
I'm like nah I'm I'm cool I was trying
to avoid the whole conversation I don't
even have this conversation with him I'm
like man I'm
I'm cool because he's like Nino Brown at
this time like no but I'm just I'm
selling enough to get tennis shoes have
my own lunch money this is not a career
my mother has a job my mother works for
a computer company yeah like I have my
mother I don't have to do that job yeah
I don't have to be out of here but but
I'm just you know in the streets
when he pulled that gun on me
I'm such a
I'm not even Brave I'm just oblivious to
the situation and I pulled like he got
the gun on me and I'm slowly reaching
for this 25 and I'm like I ain't selling
for nobody and then he snatches the gun
out my hands
he just took that
I never forget it he was like oh this is
the mother got heart and snapped the gun
out my hand
man like
my hands still up I'm like
and I don't know after that he respected
me gave him my gun back
it was like Hey man anybody ever met
what you did let me know and I and so I
end up
dealing with him on another level but
that's what I got busted with too oh it
is and he like I to this day I never
understood why he didn't listen to me
because he had been knowing me since I
was 14. I'm 19. you we've been rolling
together since then why did you listen
to somebody else other than me
and I I talk about it in the special and
this dude named MO
to this day man it just pisses me off
because
everybody was grown it was grown people
y'all was in a in their late 20s early
30s I'm 19. I keep saying the same thing
yo do y'all know this nobody is checking
out of this hotel and it is past 12
o'clock
it's like what nobody's checking out of
this hotel like not one single person
the clean I don't even see a cleaning
lady doing nothing like what and I told
him I'm like yo man don't tell Charles
don't come to this parking lot that with
that dope this man I just don't feel
right about this is that right you knew
and then when I went in I counted the
money I was the person I went in and I
counted the money
and as soon as I saw the money I started
having questions and you could tell that
they was trying to
deter like the feds were if they the
feds was involved and they was in my
special day like we were trying to
occupy his mind because he was the one
that kept saying
everything like I when I flip through
the money I flipped the money just like
that I said what's all this what's all
these numbers that's on the money
it's like okay that's Bank numbers
what
and when I gave the sign like we've done
this before and I gave the sign I just
knocked on the table three times I just
that means it's it's time to go it's we
wrapping this [__] up
I get right out the door
and say yo Moe it's the police
I said clear this day
it's on the tape it's like my attorney
was like yo you knew
I'm like yes
because the money came in hundreds and
50s drug money doesn't come like that I
knew that [__] off the top I'm like yo
man this is the pope man I said I've
been doing I've been doing this [__] too
long
dope fiends don't have hundreds in 20s
they don't make change like that it's
five tens ones twenties and the money
gonna be dirty
yeah all wrinkled up and [__] this ain't
no this ain't pressed money man I was
like I was I was pissed man when we got
busted I was pissed so when you walk out
of that room is that when they get you
nah we I I backed the the the the
minivan up me an Astro van a burgundy
Astro van I backed the Astro van up I'm
cleaning out in October because Moe was
supposed to go get Charles and I told
him hey man go tell Charles not to come
to this parking lot
hey go tell him if he drive off the most
we gonna get is
what what they gonna charge us with
coming to count the money
like what's gonna be our team pools in
that parking lot how much does he have
what's he bringing he got five kilos of
dope in that in that trunk in that trunk
and they didn't stop everybody's
everybody was being greedy they was
thinking what they were doing street
value of that back then if 92 Grand is
what we are selling them almost 100
Grand yeah so he was buying it for 92.
so it was weird man I I never understand
why grown men just didn't listen to me
and Charles was like once he we got in
court we had to go to court together and
I once again I saved everybody because
it was this judge called Ted Pope if you
look up Ted Pope Ted Pope was a monster
like he would do
I mean he would do [__] that and you
would hear about it
like like he had this dude man
he had a couple pencils on his on his
dead on the stand on his judge whatever
that is the bench the bench so he got a
couple pencils a bunch of pencils in
there he sent it to dude to like 30
years
and he said he would do stuff like this
he said um hey
you got to jump on what not I'ma I'm
gonna throw these pencils
and I have as many pencils as you catch
that's how many years I'ma take off
and do to have his jumper all open ready
to catch as many pencils and you're like
you ready yeah got the pencil cup you
get you ready they won
two three and he throw the pencils
behind the bench
he was like oh [__] like like
I think Ted post sentenced his son
and his wife
since his son is his wife Deadpool
um
my friend told me the story about he was
in court he thought his boy he said hey
man
by the time you get out of jail it's
gonna be uh um a tree outside that
window he's gonna go look go look you
know tree will be tall and dude looked
out he said there's no tree out here
he's saying then we'll be about time you
get out like he was just notorious for
giving a lot of time to people so
because I was on June 3rd with Woody
dancing
I had to
um everybody had to go to Woody dancing
because I was already in his court
so we would assign a Ted poke then he
got all shipped to Woody Denson
let me tell you the craziest thing I
ever thought
during the course of see this is why
people don't understand jail in prison
are different
that's what I want to ask you when
you're on bond or are you in jail before
you finally got sentenced and went to
prison I wasn't still in jail okay they
wouldn't they they well I was going back
to the store I went to bond reduction
and they gave me more bonds
because I said you don't know reduce me
my mother was like what the [__] is
wrong with him
so
you know just
it's weird so Woody dancing right so I'm
reading the paper every day
Woody Denson my attorney gets brought up
on briery charges
um
yeah boom this is what I [__] needed
right here oh you think this is a good
thing I'm thinking this is a great thing
oh okay because I'm thinking [__] this
is my lawyer he's dirty now and they're
gonna [__] me no this is my this is the
judge
and I'm like yo real
golden Woody
telling thirty thousand forty thousand
and then let's get this done you know
what I'm saying I'm I'm thinking this is
the movement
he's already taking those bribes
it's never going away okay man look this
hey man
my attorney once again Rio was like
so you just want me
to go to the gym
and he's like this is not confirmed if I
read it in the paper
evidence they change I judge they take
that we the same court they just changed
our judges this dude named Tim Tim Ryan
or something like that
how was he
just gave me 15 years he gave you 15.
would you serve
six
Hound 15.
why only six of the 15. that's the
statue that's that's half basically is
that the way it works yeah so they give
you a number and you serve laughed out
yeah you you do your mandatory
in Texas you didn't have to like be in
there and keep fighting the whole time
to get to six it was six it was good
behavior [__] like that I I was supposed
to actually get out in 18 months 18 to
21 months oh that's why I took the 15
because you get you get a day you get
time and a half okay in Texas so this is
how I learned about politics
this is exactly how I even got into
politics I learned about so it's 18 21
months
and Richards is the governor
and this guy comes to me and says
amen
you better tell your people to vote for
Aaron Richards
I say why
because this is our last term she can't
run for governor again he's out there
last term they don't they don't
concentrate on [__] they steal as much
money as they can before they get it
before they get out of there and just do
but if George W bush
becomes the governor oh [__] that's
right this is back then you say the
first thing when any person becomes the
governor or the mayor they they're gonna
crack down on crime
I say are you serious
he's my if Bush win everybody is going
to get what they call a set off you
don't get your date set further back
so they can show that they keep in
prisoners they being tough on crime
and I was like they can do that just
come in like all right everybody's
getting extended by three years
because you you not you got to serve not
if you already have three years right
but if you have three years and you're
supposed to get out on good behavior or
mandatory release what not they can make
you serve your whole time because you
got you you already have the three years
so they don't have to let you out that's
a privilege it's like with 15 I could
have just I could have got out at 33.
you know what I'm saying so
I'm thinking
okay I'm writing people hey make sure
you're over here riches make sure you
vote for Ann Richards you know hey hey
tell everybody vote for averages so
averages loses yeah yeah
they sent they sent it to you
in a in mail call like everyone once
everybody get in the mail that's
something that's something that's
because everybody don't get mail
everything not the whole tank don't get
mailed a couple people get mail the mail
call everybody else is be looking crazy
but if they giving them serve balls
everybody gets mailed two times when
they give them serve all and when
they're giving you your your book
statement like how much money you have
on your books whether it's zero they
gonna still give you a statement saying
that you you Indigent so
I'm
literally hearing all these people get
mailed I'm like oh [__] what is this
but it comes to me and then I see
two years set off
and it's all because
but that's how I end up getting staying
there longer then I went to school I
left and went from one prison to another
person I ended up at six different
prisons I went to school all in Texas
yeah yeah and so I'm starving I'm
serving State time so it's all in Texas
right that's right so
I went to school went to you know did a
bunch of stuff just trying to make my
winning Pro when I come up for the
parole board it looks good like he went
to cognitive intervention he went to the
drug classes which I did and learned a
lot in there and I never get this one
lady that was doing the drug the drug
classes
try to make me feel bad I did he was
like you do know that me and you are the
same you're a drug addict and I'm a drug
addict I'm like man you got me confused
I've never used drugs in my life
you're a drug addict she's like well
when I was out buying the drugs who was
out selling them
damn
and I she broke it down she said if I'm
out at three o'clock in the morning
buying drugs you out at three o'clock in
the morning
you're using it you're using the drug
the same way I'm using it I'm using it
for entertainment and to get high you're
using it for your livelihood
I can stop being entertained
how you stop your life
if you name you dependent on this
and that and those things like that
resonated with me yeah like just going
to these classes trying to make my stuff
look better cognitive intervention was
all this levels of thinking before you
react to something you know so
I was probably a bit of a
reactor instead of a responder me too
you know just kind of reaction right
away instead of thinking right away yeah
so all these things kind of helped that
I was going you know going to and going
through and I and I and I always say
that man drug dealers don't know how
much
their users
you know because I had no idea yeah
that's it's [__] that's a great point
you are depending you're more dependent
on it than actually the addict is that
it can quit you can't that's your
livelihood yeah so that's the that's why
that's a great thought and then you know
you go to these classes and you say ah
[__] and and it kind of made me a better
person and I had a lot of more I had a
lot more empathy for people who were
users and then I should have because my
pops end up
using I never get finding that out that
was kind of how were you when you found
that out I mean I was like maybe 17.
yeah and that surprised you yeah it did
because I found out was
I came on this block and these young
boys I knew they was
um bragging about
taking some these two old guy stuff
yeah we they came over we took this [__]
and I'm like oh let me see what y'all
took
and then I saw the watch my dad's watch
and I was like hey man put all that
stuff in this bag they're like damn man
you gonna just take our stuff I said
well you took it from somebody
and I never get going back
to
um
where my dad was at
and I threw the bag at him I said man he
said man what's the meaning goddamn
begging me I said man looking that bad
that's your [__]
but I'm trying to figure out how did did
this happen you over there smoking dope
my dad said Kim
talk about his friend so
I I accepted that right
and then I end up telling my mom
about it I see I say um
hey you know
these guys who I know they they um
they robbed my dad
who is that I said I want Warfare over
there [__] with that [__] that's what
my mama said I said no he said he was
with his friend and he said and my mom's
saying and you believe that
he said man I didn't put your father in
rehab
two times is that right after we were
divorced
she still helped them
yeah that really after they were
separated because it let me tell you the
craziest thing
my
um I gotta be man like 39 40.
gotta be
my mom calls me hey I need a favor
I say what you need Mom I need you to go
to Louisiana and get your daddy to sign
these divorce papers
I said what y'all have been separated
since I was like three
said but we not divorced it's official
and I don't want that [__] to
die and I have to be responsible for him
so my mom is really focused on this
so I had to go down to Louisiana and get
my dad to sign these papers
to divorce my mom and he was still
reluctant to my
I don't know
[__] why she want to be separated now
I'm like man if you don't sign these
papers man get your crazy ass out here
so I had to stick the papers for my dad
to sign them he finally signed them got
them notarized and that's how they end
up actually being divorced after all
those years since I was three damn I was
almost 40. I know for sure when I did
that so that was your mom's your mom is
still alive your dad passed yeah I
always see when he passed
um [__]
[__] he passed in 2018
February 14th so he was born in June
so maybe
60. something and like 63. what what
killed him
probably cocaine what do you think just
over the years hard at night because he
had are you think he's still doing it he
was taking some little heart medicine
and then he had
been clear
and then
I was told that his he had a heart
attack but I think he I think he
probably got happy because my he was
very happy at the end and he probably
celebrated
and then snorted something
new Hot Shot yeah
and then that's what
yeah I think that's what happened being
honest
that's
yeah that's what I'm saying it terrifies
me I'm seeing on buses Now everywhere on
buses they got fentanyl ads I have my
daughter's eight I've already had to
talk to her about it because of stuff
like that we have a friend whose
daughter died
and she he she he came to visit us and
he was crying and we're hugging and
talking and she was 20 I don't know four
or five and Baltimore got some dirty
[__] and a little bumping and killed her
and
she's like why is he crying and what
happened and I was like you know what
I'm just gonna tell you because this
shit's coming into middle schools and
everywhere else now man you need to know
about this because it is not it didn't
just say no to drugs anymore yeah it's
it's all poisoned out there all of it is
yes so I think that's one of the things
that that I actually don't mind being
the guy sometimes they talk about
drug dealing and it because I'm I'm from
a different perspective of this is not a
good thing like it affects you way more
than you think you know it makes you a
different person when you're out there
doing that and then you start to like
the the person who had the Fentanyl and
the heroin
they are they you wouldn't never even
thought it and they in their mind like I
didn't know what
um what it was I'm just doing this and
but that's it man to give somebody
something that you know that can kill
them with just a not even a a dab of it
like a a the smallest amount of this
stuff like man you savage like I would
have never done that as a drug dealer it
would never like I don't even know how
that even plays into you're also killing
your customers yeah like I don't
understand that business model yeah like
this magic star bus killed everybody
that came in that's what I'm saying just
knocking you off soon as you finish
Pizza sandwich and then die and then
like who else you're gonna serve the
sandwich too um I want to ask you a
couple questions before we wrap up I
asked this to people who've been to
prison before and I'm just curious not
saying did you enjoy your time or
anything like that but is there anything
you miss about prison when you got out
the structure or you know there's I know
it's very regimented in there is there
anything that that you still maybe even
carry with you into your adult life do
you have trouble sleeping do you know or
can you sleep no problem like what
anything this is the
this is the thing that I miss about
prison
consequences people understand the
consequences seeing a free Society
people don't understand on these
keyboards and saying whatever they want
yelling at people's faces yeah because
the level of respect in there is
different
not yeah people know like people out in
the freestyle you they'll do a bunch of
goofy [__] not understanding that they
put themselves in danger
yo
if you did this in inside
it'd have been nothing for me to tell
your [__] head off
and nobody it's not gonna I'm not gonna
be looked at no different it's gonna be
like yo man you shouldn't have did what
you did like that's the part
about it that I miss man because it get
dealt with like the I don't think people
understand the level of respect you're
going to respect
or you're going to get dealt with
it's like it's no other way you're going
all right think that you're not gonna
respect it
and it you it's no you should tell these
people all the time hey man in this
inside these walls there's no weight
class
damn you big yeah damn you small I don't
give damn you got a crew because in here
it's three things it's Lambs is wolves
and there's lions
a wolf can be a lamb because you run in
packs you need help a lion
is the line regardless and when you see
us bump heads
this [__] is terrible
it's like
I couldn't even begin to tell dudes like
man you think cause you six foot
anything you think I give a damn
you think anybody anybody on this side
of the room gives a damn
he fight he 411. he's probably going to
be worse problem that you ever have like
yo man we we on this side of the table
it is lying yeah and like
it that's the thing
you could be you know what I have to say
that is actually really interesting
because you're right there's so many
people out here that pop off in people's
faces and do all kinds of [__] up [__]
and there are no consequences
they got all these guns
[__] all that come in here no guns no no
guns no nothing it's whatever you make
and whatever you can man
I I would I would love the people to
understand
yo man you can cut you can that [__]
don't mean nothing I'm stabbed you still
I'm still breathing and now you ah man
it's just a it's a different
the type of wars that we've been in
there this is you ever seen that movie
gangs in New York yeah this is that
Savage [__]
if there were no guns just bear bear
knuckle brawling and I'll hit you in
your head with something like like if
nobody I mean I've actually beat
somebody head on this on the sea man
just with they just they hit this grab
this boom boom boom today and the type
of
savagery and violence that
to get
man I I just I I don't
I see it different like you ain't got
enough like you a [__] coward if you
gotta send somebody to me
like to be a boss in prison you got to
be able to do it yourself
all that imma send somebody to you imma
run in a pack of people don't none of
that [__] mean nothing to me you run in
the pack because you terrified
the pack
ah man it's it's
I don't think people understand how much
I miss
that like you got to come to me as a man
you got
you understand you cannot send somebody
to me and me respect you um
I don't give a damn what crew you with
and under that other [__] if the
leader of the game won't come then your
gang is [__]
and I'ma show you imma show you that I'm
coming anytime I've ever had a problem
with anybody imma show up
prison free Society whatever I'm showing
up and you got to [__] deal with me
when I show up and I know I'm a problem
oh
I don't even think you that's the
greatest question you don't understand
how much I missed that part of this [__]
like man all this dumb [__] all this I
I'm a ball [__] man
okay boss
and I tell people like this if you want
to know what I'm really [__] about
watch Mitchell
I was gonna kill a CO and go back to my
[__] sale I wasn't trying to get away
with no getaway with this [__] I'ma kill
I'm gonna go back to myself y'all come
get me when y'all figure out I did it
period
if anybody wanted to do want to get down
all you had to do is say it a step on my
toes
but in the free Society call the police
you you hide behind a crew of people you
go do all this [__] but you the one
started right all right man you hide
behind your keyboard you say all that
slick [__] and whatever but man when you
see me
okay
that's all I can tell people okay
okie dokie and you're in there if you
[__] up you're in there you might be in
there for three to five getting that ass
whooped like that you know what I mean
yo man it's gonna be a long time it's a
long this is a long haul yeah every time
that cell cracks
I see those dudes peeking out yeah man
he in the day room you [__] right I'm
out here in the day room so you sitting
yourself I decide I'm gonna go to go to
sleep or you got to kill me
or if I feel like you a threat
I ain't got no problem with taking you
out of here
like no problem
and that's that's the difference
yeah and that's even the difference out
here like I tell people man some of us
not rap as tight as you think that we
are and we just we being
humble because we don't
man I I I I was listening to this this
show and it's just it was epitome of
everything that I believe in if people
knew the type of violence
that it took to be this peaceful to be
this under control
that's all I can say to him is okay
and my mother my mother tells anybody
the problem is not when he's talking the
problem when he's quiet
because now he's contemplating he's
thinking he's trying to figure it out
but you're going to answer for it
that's why she never really worried
about me in prison because she knew the
type of heart that I got I don't have a
I ain't got no quit
and if you and I've never started to
fight
that's what makes it even more intense
because I've never started a fight in my
life
but if you decide to pick on me
or think that you're gonna pick on me
I'm so offended
I'm so offended that you chose to think
that she was gonna step on me I thought
I didn't do nothing to you okay
that's all I can say good luck with that
one and people who was in prison with me
they were like
yeah he was a bit of a problem
like this he wasn't one of the ones that
like oh go mess with him they were like
no no you see them three little ones
over there not them
me feasting to do named Elliott
all right let me ask you this the last
question I'm going to ask I'm glad I
asked that question
you got a lot to say and feel about that
um I said to you before we started
recording advice you would give to your
16 year old self now that we've talked
about everything we just talked about
here going back
what's advice you would give to your 16
year old self
be be confident enough
to stand on your own
because at the time I wasn't
as confident as I am now to just be able
to
be okay with my mom having a great job
and not
having to be in the streets
you know like a lot of people get in
these situations because they trying to
be a part of something I wish I was
independent enough just to not want to
be a part of anything just be my who I
was I was a pretty gentle
sweet basketball playing
everyday boy and then
being outside in these outside
influences and
trying to be tough not understanding
being tough was being able to stand
on your own not get into the rigament
roll was going outside so I would
definitely say to my 16 year olds I
would plead with my 16 year old self hey
man just be
confident and be in the moment and be
able to stand on your own
you know in 16 is enough to be able to
understand that you don't you don't have
to be involved in no game you don't have
to be involved no drugs you don't being
being smart is is
the toughness mental fortitude having a
little more mental fortitude I could
have learned
a lot of lessons that I learned in
prison
I already knew
from my parents talking to me you know I
didn't
just like I didn't want to be my dad is
not being an absent father I could have
not wanted to be my dad as far as
selling drugs I could just took his
business model and just been a business
person without the drugs my mom's
hard-working determination just did that
without putting that for drugs something
I don't I tell myself not to take the
easy route man yeah
is the long hard Road it's the way to go
man it is yeah dude thank you for coming
on this is great oh man thank you for
having me um promote everything one more
time you're special all that stuff
domino effect
um today yeah June the fourth make sure
y'all go out check it out as a roller
coaster
um that I I can say it's a roller
coaster I think you enjoy it
um go to my Instagram and my Tick Tock
and all this just my name Ali's d a l i
s i d d i q man that's that's all I got
man this is great dude thank you very
much present pleasure pleasure yeah man
and uh as always Ryan sickler.com Ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
yeah